Many of the stars of Superbad were launched
to instant fame after the movie became a giant
hit, but not all of them were so lucky.
Whatever happened to Martha MacIsaac?
Here's what she's been up to and how she looks
today.
In 2011, MacIsaac took on the lead role in
Hoax for the Holidays, a little-known Canadian
Christmas movie with an unusual premise.
She plays a rebellious teen who hoodwinks
the residents of her small town when she throws
her coffee against the wall of a donut store
and manipulates the stain so that it resembles
the face of Jesus Christ.
"What is it?"
"Jesus Christ."
For the Canadian MacIsaac, the film was very
much a homecoming, as she had worked with
a lot of the same crew members on the CBC
TV series Emily of New Moon when she was a
kid.
In an interview with AXS, she said,
"They were all like long-lost family.
To get to come back and see all of them as
an adult was incredible."
In 2012, MacIsaac went from playing a troublesome
teen in small-town Canada to playing a troublesome
teen in the White House.
She was a main cast member in all thirteen
episodes of the NBC sitcom 1600 Penn as the
ordinarily straitlaced but accidentally pregnant
First Daughter.
Bill Pullman, perhaps best-known for playing
the president in the sci-fi classic Independence
Day, once again took on the role of Commander
in Chief, much to the amusement of his co-stars.
In an interview with She Said Media Said,
MacIsaac confirmed that Pullman could handle
the teasing, saying,
"He's one of the nicest and down-to-earth
men I've ever had the pleasure of meeting.
He's just one of those rare gems."
MacIsaac's character also bore some coincidental
familiarity, as she was named Becca, just
like her Superbad character.
Sadly for the actress, her first full-time
American TV show didn't last very long.
It suffered mediocre reviews and was axed
by NBC after a single season.
MacIsaac married producer and director Torre
Catalano in 2010, but sadly, their union ended
just five years later.
In that time they worked together on a handful
of projects, the first of which was a 2013
short named Seasick Sailor.
The two split in 2015, the same year that
Catalano's debut feature film, Almost Anything,
later renamed Milwaukee, was released.
It's a saucy dramedy about a bunch of 30-somethings
testing the limits of monogamy.
It features MacIsaac as Greta, a woman struggling
with trust issues.
That premise seems a little awkward now that
we know her marriage to Catalano was on the
rocks at the time.
Post-divorce, MacIsaac has found a new man
in her life.
His name is Kyle McCullough, and he's dabbled
in acting, but he now appears to be focused
on working in the video game industry.
In December 2018, the two had a surprise wedding,
with none other than Paul McCartney helping
McCullough out with the proposal.
MacIsaac isn't particularly close to any of
the guys from Superbad, but she and Emma Stone
remain near and dear friends, having even
spent a few years living together.
In 2012, MacIsaac presented her pal with the
first ever MTV Trailblazer Award, a title
that Stone has more than lived up to in the
years since.
She got her first Oscar nomination for 2014's
Birdman and then won a couple of years later
for La La Land.
And just like best friends should be, MacIsaac
has been right by Stone's side every step
of the way.
"Emma has proven herself as one of the most
enduring and captivating actresses of our
generation.
She's a gifted entertainer and a very dear
friend."
In 2017, MacIsaac joined fellow actresses
Ahna O'Reilly and Sugar Lyn Beard for a pre-Oscars
get together, with all three sporting t-shirts
in support of Stone's bid for Best Actress.
A couple of months after the Oscar buzz had
died down, Stone and MacIsaac went to a relaxing
trip to Sonoma in northern California, a picturesque
city located in the heart of a world-renowned
winemaking region.
MacIsaac's most recent major film role was
in 2017's sports biopic Battle of the Sexes.
It's based on the true story of the 1973 exhibition
match between Billie Jean King and Bobby Riggs,
a historic moment in the history of women's
tennis.
King won in three straight sets, meaning Riggs,
who had belittled women's tennis in the media,
had to eat his words.
King was played by Emma Stone, and her bestie
was right there alongside her.
MacIsaac had the honor of playing Jane "Peaches"
Bartkowicz, who was a member of the Original
9, a group of female players that included
King and changed tennis forever.
As it turns out, the fact that MacIsaac and
Stone are BFFs in real life actually helped
her land the role.
Co-director Valerie Faris told CinemaBlend,
"She and Emma are friends, and it just felt
like if we build this group of women that
have a certain camaraderie, that can't hurt."
In addition to Battle of the Sexes, MacIsaac
has appeared in a couple of small, independent
films the past few years.
First up was Unicorn Store, the directorial
debut of Brie Larson.
It features Larson as a woman who receives
a mysterious invitation to fulfill her dreams.
The film also stars Samuel L. Jackson, Joan
Cusack, and Bradley Whitford, and it had its
world premiere at the 2017 Toronto International
Film Festival.
Next up was the thriller What Keeps You Alive,
which premiered at the 2018 South by Southwest
Festival.
It's about a couple celebrating their first
anniversary at a remote cabin.
MacIsaac plays a former childhood friend who
arouses suspicion when she shows up.
As for the future, MacIsaac unfortunately
doesn't appear to have any film or TV projects
arriving anytime soon.
But judging by her Instagram, she's been keeping
herself busy by baking delicious-looking cakes.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
actors and actresses are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.